[Music]
in the last video we saw what an
electromagnet is any conductors such as
a straight wire through which electric
current is flowing is an electromagnet
that's because there's a magnetic field
around it however we can make the magnet
strong by wrapping the wire around a
piece of iron such as an iron nail even
if the current is the same in both cases
this one will result in a stronger
magnetic field now there are some
factors on which the strength of the
electromagnet and the current flowing in
the wire is one of them if we increase
the flow of the current in the wire the
strength of the magnetic field of this
electromagnet will also increase is
there any other way yes there is another
way to increase the strength of this
magnetic field is by increasing the
number of turns of the wire around the
nail more the number of turns stronger
the magnetic field will be we will learn
about these factors in much more detail
in our higher grade in this video we
will see a few applications of
electromagnet so where do we use them
you must have seen large machines used
to lift up cars they have an
electromagnet in them this electromagnet
is so strong that it can lift the whole
weight of the car electromagnets are
also used to separate metal objects from
a pile of junk
now what if I tell you that they are
used in the fastest trains around the
world yes
the Shanghai maglev train is started as
the world's fastest train and it works
on the concept of electromagnetism let's
understand the use of electromagnets in
simple devices such as electric belts
yes most of the bells we see nowadays
are electric bells here's a very
simplistic diagram of an electric Bell
this is the inner structure of the Bell
let me first tell you the names of the
basic components this is a push switch
which is nothing but the switch we
pressed when we ring the bell this is
the coil of wire wound around an iron
piece there could be two coils of wire
wound around an iron piece as well
remember we've just drawn a simplistic
version of the actual circuit so it will
act as an electromagnet when the
electric current flows through the
circuit this is a battery and this is a
striker which strikes this Gong that's
when we hear the sound so we can see
that this is a circuit that can be
formed it's not complete why is it not
complete
well we haven't pressed the switch here
when we push the button this circuit
gets completed and the current flows
from the positive to the negative
terminal but when the current flows
through the coil it becomes an
electromagnet this electromagnet then
attracts this soft iron towards it and
in the process the striker strikes the
Gong and the sound is produced but
notice what happens when the striker
hits the gong as soon as the soft iron
is shifted away from its original spot
the circuit breaks it's no longer
connects this wire with the terminal of
the battery and when the circuit breaks
the current stops flowing so this
electromagnet gets demagnetized after
which the soft iron goes back to its
start position this process will
continue until the switches open again
as soon as we release the push button
the circuit breaks and the Bell stops
ringing that's the basic idea of how an
electric Bell works
[Music]